et maintenant samedi
pour moi
ouais si julie depardieu et yann moix
suivi de pardieu ian white bonsoir à
tous les deux vous êtes ici évidemment
pour punjabi inutile de le cacher plus
longtemps
film de yann moix avec julie depardieu
jean paul rouve et benoît poelvoorde
le pitch or là vous allez le faire
puisque vous avez fait le bouquin est le
fils sèche peut pas le faire le pitch si
l'histoire d'un sosie de claude françois
qui a raccroché
ouais et un de ses meilleurs amis venant
voir une grande série mais ne dessaisit
organisé par evelyne thomas le pousse à
recommencer à retomber dans son vice qui
cote françois au grand dam de sa femme
interprétée par juillet par l'ue voilà
et son métier c'est peu devant soi